- We are back with Joel
McHale and Storm Reed
and Colorado Peaches softball
team, Maggie and Betsy.
All right, as you may know,
I'm not exactly into sports bowl
but I am into winning.
So it's time for a game people.
We're at our bowls of sports board
and I have these awesome gloves on
and in honor of the Colorado
Peaches softball team,
today's game is called tic-tac snow.
(upbeat music)
So Storm has graciously offered to host
so I can beat Joel.
Storm tell everyone how this works.
- Okay, y'all this game
is Kelly and Ms. Betsy
verses Joel and Ms. Maggie.
- You're going down, you're going down.
And you win by getting
three squares in a row.
So like tic-tac-toe on the big board
and you can win a square,
when you throw a ball
from behind the line,
no cheating, behind them line
and getting the ball.
- No, wait, wait, wait
in front of the line?
- [Storm] Behind.
- [Kelly] Got it.
- Behind you thought, you
thought you were tricky.
Okay, behind the line and
then you throw the snowball
in the hole on the square.
And because it's winter and
the Peaches are from Colorado,
the balls are made of snow.
- [Kelly] Yes.
(audience woos)
- Also I'm told, if Joel's team wins,
you guys get to be on
the wall of champions,
which is really cool.
- It's not, it's a boring
wall, it's a dumb wall.
- It's a done deal.
- [Kelly] It's a dumb wall.
- They've already made space
- It doesn't even matter, the wall.
- Well, let the games begin.
Are you guys ready?
- [Both] Yes.
- Okay, so who's first?
- Maggie.
- Okay, honors go to age so
Ms. Maggie, you are first
and I'm gonna step over here.
- [Kelly] Get it Maggie.
- Let's do it.
- Careful Maggie, careful now.
- Watch it, watch it.
- Oh, we got some trash talk.
(contestants chatter)
(all chuckle)
- Which one you're going to for Mag?
- Don't mess up.
- Come on careful now.
- Don't think about it.
- I'm not telling you
which one I'm going for.
- [Group] Whoa.
- She's a big arm.
Okay, okay.
- Okay, you guys are next.
So Ms. Betsy, you're next.
I'm gonna step over here.
- Don't you fail me, get
whatever one you can make.
- [Betsy] Whatever one I can make.
- 'Cause I can't.
(audience cheers)
(buzz sound)
- Okay, come on Joel, come on Joel.
- Come on Joel.
- No, wait he's bigger, he
should have to be back here.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] You have an arm on
you, you have a longer arm.
(audience chuckles)
- I'm gonna go for the center
square, here we go, ready?
(trumpet blows)
- [Betsy] You can do it Kelly, here we go.
- I guess it's just left to
me, Maggie what you doing?
- [Betsy] Maggie's trying to rush.
(audience cheers)
Come on Kelly.
- [Joel] Let's do it Kelly.
(all cheer)
- Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
- Uh-oh, all right, your turn.
Head for the three in a row.
- That one's mine.
- Careful now Maggie, careful.
- Don't mess up, Maggie, don't mess up.
(dramatic music)
Oh, almost, almost, almost, almost.
Okay, come on Betsy, come on.
- You suck.
(audience chuckles)
- I'm used to it, this one melted.
- Don't get the melted
one, no, get a strong one.
- [Joel] Okay, don't melt it.
(dramatic music)
(all cheer)
- Oh my God, all I do is win, win, win,
all I do is win, win, win.
- No, not his face.
They tried to put his face in there.
(audience cheer)
- [Storm] You guys are about to lose.
- No we're not.
- [Betsy] Oh, now you can go
low 'cause you're a bowler.
- That went in, that went in.
- That went in that was awesome.
- That went in.
- [Kelly] So wait, it's my turn.
- Go for the football or the tennis ball.
You can do it.
- Okay, okay.
It seems hard not to
want to hit your face,
I'm gonna be honest with you.
(audience chuckles)
- [Storm] Come on, Ms. Kelly.
- Oh, I didn't get it, I
didn't get it, I didn't get it.
- [Betsy] Part of it went in.
- I was close, I was close.
(contestants chatter)
- Do the bottom row, bottom row,
bottom row.
- Careful Maggie, careful now.
- Don't worry, don't worry,
you totally got this.
Don't let it get in your head,
don't let it get in your
head. (audience groans)
- [Storm] Dang it.
- [Kelly] All right, come on Betsy.
Okay, let's do it, let's do it,
let's do it.
Hit that tennis ball, that football,
whichever one you want.
- Whatever one I want.
- [Kelly] I know how to
play tic-tac-toe now.
Yes.
♪ Oh my God, oh my God ♪
- They're pretty darn good,
they're pretty darn good.
- See, you can't cheat this, honey.
You're gonna actually hit,
aim and hit the hole, yeah.
- I'm gonna do under hand, okay.
- Careful now, don't step over that line.
- That's right it's hard,
look at those feet, good Lord.
- Don't let us get in your head about it.
- Can I have silence?
Here we go.
(dramatic music)
(ding sound)
- He got you good.
This is a tough competition.
- Okay, I'm gonna go for the golf.
- Yeah, go for the golf,
good move, good move.
- I mean, I guess I'm
gonna try and like...
(all cheer)
- [Storm] That's good for you guys.
- Top left, top left, top left.
It's all, it's all we got.
- [Betsy] So we got two chances now.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Okay, speed round y'all.
So you guys have 30 seconds left
and whoever makes the
most shots is the winner.
(dramatic music)
(contestants chatter)
Okay, so that means--
- It's a cotton one.
- I got him (mumbles).
- Let's not snowball fight you guys.
That sound means that the time is up
and Kelly and Ms. Betsy win.
(audience cheers)
High fives all round.
- Oh, yeah, high five, yup.
(Kelly chuckles)
Good game every body and a big hand
to Storm Reed for hosting.
(audience applaud)